one ahumada en lengua indígena embera
que se traduce como vamos con todo es el
nombre de la nueva campaña de panamá que
busca reforzar la vigilancia en la
frontera sur del país la nación
centroamericana anunció que pretende
entre otros objetivos frenar el
narcotráfico desde sudamérica
principalmente desde colombia hacia eeuu
lo principal interés que hay en la
campaña juana jugán anda es operaciones
de seguridad para evitar lo que son el
tráfico de drago de droga para evitar la
trata de personas para evitar los
delitos ambientales como la
contaminación del río la tala de la tala
de árboles no es el primer reforzamiento
militar en la frontera que se anuncia
pero esta vez se da con la intención
declarada de contener la inmigración
irregular luego de que la selva del
darién se convirtiera en un peligroso
corredor de paso para personas en
condición de movilidad humana
y lo dejan en el cordón fronterizo
exactamente en el mismo
y la mono donde divide panamá con
colombia los dejan ahí en la orilla en
esas playas en ese pedreguer o
y ellos entonces inician su marcha
costera hacia la que alguna veces
tenemos que ir a rescatarlos a ellos en
la frontera entre panamá y colombia la
selva de darién se extiende a lo largo
de
266 km y sudamericanos asiáticos y
africanos que buscan llegar a los eeuu
se enfrentan a múltiples enemigos como
los grupos criminales que se aprovechan
de su situación de vulnerabilidad
según cifras oficiales casi 134 mil
migrantes principalmente haitianos y
cubanos cruzaron el darién durante 2021
una cifra que sobrepasa todo lo
acumulado entre 2010 y 2020